สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะค่ะสวัสดีค่ะวันนี้
วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 3
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 2
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอาทิตย์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 4
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
กี่โมงตอนนี้เวลาบ่ายโมงค่ะ
บ่ายโมงกี่นาที
บ่ายโมง 26 นาที
บ่ายโมง 26 นาทีนะคะก็เป็นเวลา
กลางวันใช่ไหมคะเป็นตอนกลางวันที่
ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยบ่ายโมง 26 นาทีหรอคะตอน
นี้ใช่ค่ะคุณหญิงที่ออสเตรเลียบ่ายโมง 26
นาทีค่ะ
[เพลง]
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่ออสเตรเลียมา 2 เดือนแล้ว
ค่ะ
ครูฟ้าอยู่ 2 เดือน
แต่ครูหญิงคิดเหมือนๆครูฟ้าไปอยู่
ออสเตรเลียสัก 6 เดือนแล้วนะ
เหมือนนานมากๆอ่ะ
แต่ 2 เดือนนะคะ
แล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่ 2 เดือนครูฟ้าเนี่ย
คิดถึง
คิดถึงประเทศไทยไหมคะ
ประโยชน์ออสเตรเลีย 2 เดือนแล้วแบบ
คิดถึงประเทศไทยอยากกลับประเทศไทยอยาก
กลับประเทศไทยคิดถึงประเทศไทยไหมคุณครู
ฟ้า
ไม่คิดถึงประเทศไทย
เลย
อ้าว
ครูฟ้าครูฟ้าไม่รักประเทศไทยหรอ
กูฟังไม่รักอากาศร้อนนะคะนักเรียน
เค้าเบื่อกันร้อนมาก
ประเทศไทยแค่
40 องศาเอง
40 องศา
OK ครูฟ้าเนี่ยอากาศร้อนไม่ก็เลยไม่คิด
ถึงประเทศไทยแล้วไม่คิดถึง
อาหารหรออาหารไทยอ่ะ
นักเรียนค่ะ
อันนี้อะไรอ่ะ
อันนี้คือกุ้งแบบว่าเหมือน
กุ้งซาซิมินะคะอันนี้ผัดกระเพราปลานะคะ
ก็คือครูฟ้าอยู่ 2 เดือนกินอาหารไทยทุก
วันอันนี้กุ้งอบวุ้นเส้นนะคะนักเรียน
กุ้งอบวุ้นเส้น
นี่มีน้ำจิ้มซีฟู้ดด้วย
เหมือนประเทศไทยเลย
กินทอดมันด้วยนะ
เข้าใจแล้วทำไมครูฟ้าไม่คิดถึงประเทศไทย
มีอาหารไทยให้กินทุกวันทุกวันทุกวัน
เลยไม่คิดถึงประเทศไทยเท่าไหร่นะคะ
แต่
อะไรแต่อยากกิน
แต่อยากกินทุเรียน
ออสเตรเลียไม่มีทุเรียนหรอ
มีค่ะครูฟ้ากินไปแล้ว
อร่อยไหม
อร่อยเหมือนพริกไทยไหม
แต่ว่า
มีทุเรียน
ไปแล้วนะคะมีทุเรียนอยู่
เหมือนกันด้วย
แต่ว่าราคาแพงมากเลยกินนิดหน่อย
แต่ว่ามันไม่คุ้มฟ้าคือครูฟ้าเนี่ยอยู่
ออสเตรเลียคือฟ้าได้กินอาหารไทยทุกวันแต่
ครูฟ้าไม่คิดถึงแบบเวลาครูฟ้า
กำลังนอนอยู่หรือว่าครูฟ้า
บ่ายสามโมงหิวแล้วก็เปิดประตูออกจากบ้าน
แล้วก็เดินไปถนนแล้วก็ตรงฟุตบาทเนี่ยมี
อาหารอาหารอาหารอาหารขายฟังไม่คิดถึงหรอ
แบบนี้อ่ะ
อุ๊ยอาหารที่ฟุตบาทเหรอคะ
ใช่เห็นไหมมีผลไม้ขายที่ Football มีไก่
ทอดมีลูกชิ้นปิ้งมีข้าวกล่อง
[เพลง]
เพราะมันหนาว
ไม่มีมอเตอร์ไซค์ด้วย
เนี่ยออสเตรเลียก็ไม่มีนะ
อาหารก็ไม่มี
อาหารที่นี่เนี่ยราคาถูกมากเลยนะคะ
อย่างนักเรียนเห็นแตงโมไหมเนี่ยเพราะว่า
แตงโมเนี่ยประมาณ
20 บาท
ด้วย
20 บาท 15 บาทประมาณนี้ราคาถูกมากเลยนะ
ใช่อร่อยนะ
[เพลง]
แต่ผู้หญิงคิดว่าที่ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยต้อง
มีฟุตบาทแน่นอนเนี่ยฟุตบาท
คือจริงๆเนี่ยคนไทยเรียก Football เรียก
คางเท้านะพูดได้ 2 อย่างแต่ผู้หญิงคิดว่า
คนไทยประมาณ
87% เรียกฟุตบอล
คิดแบบนั้น
ที่ออสเตรเลีย
ฟุตบาทที่ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยไม่มีรถเข็นแบบ
นี้อันนี้เป็นรถเข็นนะคะแต่เป็นรถเข็นขาย
อาหารเนี่ยฟุตบาทที่ออสเตรเลียเนี่ยไม่มี
ใช่ไหม
ไม่มีค่ะไม่มี
สายแตกฟุตบาทที่เมืองไทยฟุตบาทที่ประเทศ
ไทยเนี่ยมีหมดนะคะมีทุกที่นะ
เรียนมาประเทศไทยโดยเฉพาะถ้านักเรียนมา
กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยกรุงเทพฯนะคะนักเรียนมีรถ
แท็กซี่มีอีมอเตอร์ไซค์นักเรียนคิดดูว่า
มอเตอร์ไซค์ขับไปทางนี้แท็กซี่ออกมาทาง
นี้
เป็นถนนที่
น่ากลัวนะคะ
งงดีนะคะนักเรียนมากรุงเทพฯนะคะถึงแม้ตอน
นี้นะ
2023 นักเรียนเดินบนฟุตบาทที่กรุงเทพฯ
เนี่ยก็จะมีรถเข็นรถเข็นขายอาหารเนี่ยยัง
มีอยู่นะคะแต่อาจจะไม่ได้มีมากๆไม่ได้มี
บนไม่ได้มีทุกๆฟุตบาททุกๆถนนเหมือนเมื่อ
ก่อนนะคะแต่มีอันนี้เนี่ยถ้านักเรียนเห็น
นักเรียนไม่เคยรู้แล้วมาเห็นนักเรียนอาจ
จะรู้สึกโอ้โหตกใจนิดหน่อยหรือเปล่านะคะ
ทำไมขายของบนฟุตบาทหรือว่าแบบนี้ก็ได้นะ
เนี่ยเห็นไหม
คนเดินเนี่ยมีคนเดินบนฟุตบาทจริงๆอันนี้
คิดว่าขายไม่ได้นะ
รถเข็น
คิดว่าผิด
ว่าตรง BTS ตรงนี้น่าจะไม่ได้นะคิดว่าผิด
นะคะแต่ได้เห็นไหมมีน้ำส้มขาย
บนฟุตบาทมีรถเข็นใช่ไหมรถเข็นขายอาหารมี
คนเดินนะจริงๆฟุตบาทเนี่ยเราไว้ให้คนเดิน
ขายของไม่ได้หรือมอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ยจะขี่บน
ฟุตบาทไม่ได้แต่กรุงเทพฯก็ยังกรุงเทพฯอาจ
จะน้อยนะมอเตอร์ไซค์บ่นฟุตบาทเนี่ยแต่ถ้า
ไม่ใช่กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยน่าจะยังเยอะนะคะหรือ
ว่า
เป็นไงล่ะ
คนเนี่ยเห็นไหมคะนักเรียน
ฟุตบาทเนี่ยไว้ให้คนเดินแต่กรุงเทพฯเนี่ย
คนเดินที่ถนนฟุตบาทเนี่ยมีโต๊ะมีเก้าอี้
กินข้าว
เอ้าสรุปฟุตบาทเอาไว้ทำอะไรคะ
ไม่ได้เอาไว้ให้คนเดินใช่ไหมเอาไว้
2 เอาไว้ตั้งโต๊ะอันนี้ฝรั่งนั่งด้วยนะ
คะเห็นไหมนั่งโต๊ะ
กินก๋วยเตี๋ยว
นี่ฟุตบาทประเทศไทย
แต่ยังไม่หมดนะครูฟ้า
ยังมีอะไรอีกคะ
อันนี้เนี่ยก็ไม่รู้ว่ามันจะเป็นของที่
อยู่บนฟุตบาทไหมแต่ผู้หญิงคิดว่าเวลาเดิน
บนฟุตบาทที่กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยนอกจากเห็นโต๊ะ
ขายอาหารแล้วอ่ะนักเรียนมันจะเห็นเสาไฟ
ฟ้าแบบนี้
อยู่บนฟุตบาท
ทุกครั้ง
ไม่ใช่นะคะนักเรียนอันนี้คือเสาไฟฟ้านะคะ
ไฟฟ้าเหมือนเวลาเราชาร์จ
แม้เรามีโทรศัพท์แล้วมีปลั๊กแล้วก็ชาร์จ
เนี่ยเสาไฟนะคะ
แต่ว่ากรุงเทพฯเนี่ยบางที่ยังอยู่บน
ฟุตบาทนะไม่ใช่แค่กรุงเทพฯนะคะนักเรียน
เมืองไทยประเทศไทยเนี่ยนักเรียนเดินอัน
นี้ยังดีนะเนี่ยเห็นไหมเนี่ยฟุตบาทตรงนี้
ใช่ไหมเขายังอยู่ริมริมฟุตบาทบางที่เนี่ย
เสาไฟเนี่ยสมมุติอันนี้เป็นอ่าอันนี้เป็น
ถนนนะคะนักเรียนเป็นถนนใช่ไหมตรงนี้เป็น
ฟุตบาท
บางครั้งเนี่ยเสาไฟเนี่ยอยู่ตรงกลางเลยนะ
คะอยู่ตรงกลางถ้านักเรียนมีเด็กๆแล้วมีรถ
ใช่ไหมรถเข็นน่ะ
ยังไงอ่ะ
มันว่ายังไงก็ไม่รู้อ่ะ
มีรถเข็นน่ะ
อันนี้คุณพ่อใช่ไหมคุณพ่อก็จับแล้วก็เข็น
เข็นเด็กอ่ะค่ะบางครั้งอ่ะเสาไฟมันอยู่
มันอยู่ตรงกลางอ่ะรถเข็นเนี่ยไปทางซ้ายก็
ไม่ได้ไปทางขวาก็ไม่ได้ก็มีเห็นไหมเป็น
งานอาร์ตเหมือนที่ครูฟ้าบอกจริงๆนะคะเสา
ไฟเนอะ
เวลาเราเดินเนี่ยเราก็จะเห็นประมาณนี้
แหละค่ะแต่ไม่รู้ว่าที่ออสเตรเลียฟุตบาท
ฟุตบาทที่ออสเตรเลีย
มีอะไร
ไหมอ่ะเหมือนกรุงเทพฯไหม
มีอะไรอยู่บนฟุตบาทไหมถ้ากรุงเทพฯเนี่ยก็
มีนี่ใช่ไหม
ขายของขายอาหารโต๊ะกินข้าว
เสาไฟฟ้า
ที่ออสเตรเลียฟุตบาทที่ออสเตรเลียมีอะไร
ไหมคะ
หรือว่าไม่มีเลยนะคะเพราะมีรูปให้ดูนะคะ
หรอ
คะมีเรือ
จริงหรอ
นี่คือฟุตบาทที่ออสเตรเลียใช่ไหมนี่คือ
ถนน
นะคะแล้วก็ฟุตบาท
แปลว่าเดินไปหน้าเป็นบ้านแล้วก็น่าจะมี
น้ำหรือว่ามีน้ำตรงนี้นะคะมีรถด้วย
เดี๋ยวอันนี้ฟุตบาทออสเตรเลียหรือว่า
ฟุตบาทประเทศไทยคะ
ตุ้ยฟุตบาทออสเตรเลียมีแบบนี้คะ
นี่นะคะ
แต่เขามีต้นไม้ไงใช่ไหมมีต้นไม้
ฟุตบาทที่ไทยไม่ค่อยมีต้นไม้ไหมก็จะมีแบบ
ดอกไม้อาจจะมีดอกไม้เล็กๆนะคะแต่ฟุตบาท
ออสเตรเลียมีเรือ
มีเรือ
แต่ว่าไม่มีไม่มีอาหารขายแบบนี้ใช่ไหมครู
ฟ้า
ใช่ค่ะไม่มีค่ะ
ฟุตบาทออสเตรเลียไม่มีอาหารขายเลย
มีแบบเสื้อผ้าไหมเสื้อผ้าอาจจะมีแบบมีคน
มีมีปูผ้าตรงนี้ใช่ไหมมีผ้าวางอยู่แล้ว
ตอนนี้มีคนแล้วตรงนี้ก็จะมีแบบมีเสื้อ
มีรองเท้า
มีกระเป๋า
ขายบนฟุตบาทอันนี้ไม่ใช่อาหารฟุตบาทที่
ออสเตรเลียมีไหมคะ
ไม่มีค่ะตั้งแต่คุณฟ้าเดินมาไม่มีค่ะ
ล้อแต่ฟุตบาทที่ที่นิวยอร์กมีนะครูฟ้า
ใช่แล้วแบบว่ามันจะมี
มากกว่าตรงที่ว่าไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนรู้จัก
อาจจะรู้จักหรือเปล่านะคะคือที่นิวยอร์ก
เนี่ยมันจะมีถนนถนนหนึ่งถนนที่ชื่อว่า
เมนูคิดว่าเคยได้ยินไหมเนี่ยก็จะมีร้านมี
ร้านแบบแบรนด์เนมแบบหลุยส์วิคตอง
แชแนล
คริสเตียนดีออมมันจะมีร้านแบรนด์เนม
แบรนด์เนมเยอะๆร้านแบบไทยมากๆแพงๆใช่ไหม
คะแล้วบนฟุตบาท
ก็จะมีคนนะคะมีคนแล้วเขาก็จะมีภาพมีภาพ
ปู่อันนี้เป็นคริสเตียนดีออกชาแนลหรือ
วิคตองใช่ไหมตรงนี้ก็จะมีคริสเตียน Dior
Copy
บนถนน fift  Avenue คุณหญิงก็แบบคือ
ประเทศไทยก็มีนะแต่ประเทศไทยไม่มีขายแบบ
นี้นะบนฟุตบาท
ไม่รู้อ่ะค่ะอันนี้ผู้หญิงเห็นนะฟุตบาท
ที่นิวยอร์กเนี่ยมีคนขายแบบ Louis
Vuitton ส่วนใหญ่จะเป็นคริสเตียนดีออก
กับหลุยส์วิตตองที่เป็น Copy มากๆมากๆนะ
คะ
แล้วก็มีอีกอย่างนึงที่ผู้หญิงเห็นเยอะๆ
บนฟุตบาทที่นิวยอร์กเนี่ยก็คืออีพวกกล่อง
เนี่ยค่ะนักเรียนตู้ๆๆสีแดงสีน้ำเงินสี
เหลืองอันนี้ถังขยะนะคะอันนี้ถังขยะนะ
เวลาเราใช้ทิชชู่เสร็จแล้วก็ทิ้งทิ้งที่
ถังขยะแต่ครูฟ้ารูปว่าอันเนี้ย
อะไร
คุณฟ้าดูแล้ว
ATM
ไม่ใช่ตู้
ฟุตบาทประเทศไทยไม่มีตู้ atm เนอะไม่มี
ไม่มีไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่ใช่ตู้ atm อันนี้ฟรีนะ
ป๊าเนี่ยเดินเดินมาเปิดแล้วก็หยิบได้
คืออะไรอ่ะ
อะไรนะคะ
ตู้ใส่หนังสือพิมพ์ข้างในนี้เนี่ยข้างใน
ข้างในเนี่ยจะมีหนังสือพิมพ์เป็นหนังสือ
พิมพ์ฟรีอาจจะไม่ใช่
นิวยอร์กไทม์ไม่ใช่หนังสือพิมพ์อย่างนั้น
ตู้ใส่หนังสือพิมพ์จะมีหนังสือพิมพ์เนี่ย
อยู่ในนี้ครูฟ้าเดินมาแล้วก็เปิดแล้วก็
หยิบหนังสือพิมพ์ 1 ฉบับเอาไปอ่านได้ตอน
นี้ก็ยังมีนะ
2023 อะก็มีหนังสือพิมพ์คนก็ยังเปิดแล้ว
ก็หยิบหนังสือพิมพ์
[เพลง]
ดีมากเลยค่ะฟรีด้วยนะคะเพราะว่าคุณฟ้า
เนี่ยก็ซื้อหนังสือพิมพ์ของออสเตรเลียมา
แต่กี่ออสเตรเลียดอลลาร์ไม่รู้อ่ะแต่ไม่
ฟรี 1 ฉบับใช่
5 ดอลลาร์หรือเปล่าถึงแม้ไม่รู้ไม่ชัวร์
นะคะ
5 ดอลลาร์ก็เกือบๆ 100 บาทเนอะ
อย่างใกล้ๆอพาร์ทเม้นท์ครูหญิงอ่ะตู้
หนังสือพิมพ์เป็นภาษาจีน
ก็ไม่รู้ว่าตู้ไหนนะ
เคยเห็นมีผู้ชาย 1 คนอายุประมาณแบบ 60 ปี
อ่ะค่ะเขาเดินแล้วก็เปิดแล้วก็หยิบมาก็
เห็นหนังสือพิมพ์เป็นภาษาจีนนะเพราะว่า
ใกล้ๆ area ที่คุยอยู่มันเป็น China  Town
ไงครูฟ้าก็เลยมีแบบหนังสือพิมพ์ภาษาจีนจะ
อ่านออกนะคะผู้หญิงเขาอ่านออกไงแต่ผู้
หญิงเนี่ยไม่ได้อ่านไม่ได้นะคะอ่ะแต่
ฟุตบาทที่นิวยอร์กเนี่ยยังมีอีกอย่างนึง
นะที่เดี๋ยวให้ครูฟ้าดูแล้วครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ที่ไทยมีไหมคือบนฟุตบาทเนี่ยเขาจะมี
เก้าอี้ให้นั่งแต่ไม่ได้ขายอาหารนะ
อ้าวแล้วนั่งทำไมอ่ะ
ใครนั่งก็ได้สมมุติครูฟ้าเดินๆมา
แล้วรู้สึกเหนื่อยอยากนั่งหรือไปซื้อ
แฮมเบอร์เกอร์อาหารมากินแล้วก็นั่งกินได้
ฟรี
[เพลง]
ฟรีค่ะฟรี
หรือว่าเป็นแบบนี้ก็มีนะ
เนี่ยเห็นไหมอันนี้เป็นฟุตบาทใช่ไหม
ฟุตบาทที่ที่นี่เนี่ยบางคนก็เดินบางคน
เนี่ยก็วิ่งหรือว่าบางคนก็มานั่งอย่างนี้
ค่ะ
บางทีแบบมีแดดร้อนมากเลยนะเขาก็นั่งดู
นั่งอ่านหนังสือ
ซึ่งผู้หญิงเป็นคนไทยรู้สึก
นั่งอ่านหนังสือหรอ
คิดว่าที่ไทยไม่มีเนาะ
[เพลง]
แต่นี่ไม่ใช่แค่ bus  stop มันยาวไปเลย
อ่ะ
เรานั่งๆๆ
แต่อาจจะเป็นแค่ที่นิวยอร์กหรือเปล่านะคะ
อันนี้ก็ไม่รู้เนาะแล้วฟุตบาทที่ประเทศ
นักเรียนล่ะคะมีอะไรบ้างมีเหมือนไทยมี
เหมือนนิวยอร์กมีเหมือนออสเตรเลียไหมมี
เรือนะ
คะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้ผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อน
เนาะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้า
นะคะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ